it's far from the biggest difference
between the matrix and that sequels but
funds going back to watch the film that
kick-started the Matrix trilogy might
always have wondered just what happened
to tank in the films the operator of the
Nebuchadnezzar died off screen in
between 1999 sir matrix and 2003 sir
Matrix Reloaded as the first movie ended
with tank being grievously injured that
story track of the series own internal
logic but that's not the real story of
white tank actor Marcus Cheung didn't
join the rest of the castle the matrix
for the following two films in fact
Chong torpedoed his own chances to
appear in the following movies in
contract negotiations and to spend the
interceding years trying to tell his
side of the story via a little scene
home made documentary and an even less
read book prior to the matrix Marcus
Chong was an actor on the rise he had
spent most of his life in the
entertainment business appearing in a
number of television roles as well as in
a range of Hollywood movies and then
seen that Cheung could achieve household
name status or something very close to
it when he landed the role of tank and
the matrix but although his performance
in the film as memorable enough Chung's
Korea hit an incredibly rough patch
after the first matrix wrapped in May
2003 the same month the Matrix Reloaded
hit theaters Chong filed a lawsuit
against Warner Brothers pictures
claiming that the matrix directors and
franchise creators Lana and Lily
wachowski have breached both written and
verbal agreements to bring tank back for
the second and third Matrix movies
according to the Guardian the actor also
alleged that the Wachowski sub published
false claims about him being a terrorist
though that hasn't ever been
corroborated it appears that the reason
for the alleged preaching of these
agreements came about after a heated
discussion over Chong salary for the
matrix evidently Chong wanted much more
money than one of brothers was willing
to pay him for the Matrix Reloaded which
was apparently much less than his fellow
actors received photographs from the
2003 lawsuit showed in a documentary
Chong himself made revealed that Warner
Brothers offered the actor
$400,000 for both Matrix sequels but
Chung wanted to be paid 1 million
dollars and received the same publicity
as a film stars Warner Brothers didn't
agree to this counteroffer Chung was
subsequently arrested on October 18 2005
days following the supposed breakdown in
discussion about his salary demands
soon after it was revealed that he had
been arrested for allegedly making
repeated threats over the phone
Chong was then written out of the Matrix
Reloaded and the Matrix Revolutions in
interviews after the fact and in his
2003 lawsuit John claims Warner Brothers
and The Matrix creative team was
intentionally strongarm in him into a
bad contract he told that I am NOT so
Hollywood podcast they wanted to start
me out hold all my monies take all my
residuals now give me any pension credit
not any health care in the same
interview though Cheung admitted to
threatening their with Chelse keys after
negotiations with Warner Brothers broke
down and I said if you send anyone to my
home to prod me I will come and kill you
but Chung's attack on the producers of
The Matrix extended well beyond the
lawsuit in question in the 2018
documentary made by Cheung the actor
laid out a number of claims against
pretty much everyone involved in the
Matrix movies he accused Keanu Reeves of
theft said that Warner Brothers tried to
force him into signing a non-union
contract and littered his video with
transphobic remarks about the Wachowskis
the Hollywood press doesn't exactly
paint the one Matrix movie on which
Cheung worked as a cakewalk either
speaking with Entertainment Weekly Chong
is said to have owned up to crashing a
press junket and stealing food from
production offices among other things
during his time working on the matrix
given that's it's easy to see why he
hasn't worked much sense as casting in
the Matrix Reloaded fell through whereas
chong sees a conspiracy to blackmail him
it might be more likely that people saw
his arrest public pot-stirring and
lawsuit and decided that hiring Kim just
wasn't worth the hustle check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos but your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]